[Musique]
regardez le collier de regarder les
kabyles et steria
regardez le way s'est dit vrai marbre ça
m'a dit vraiment on déclare a commencé
tout en fait mais mes côtés je vous
remercie dieu vient d'avouer bien la
prévent les petits charte du joueur
quitte bien ouais on adore on a fumé n'a
pas rebuté
yes regardez la elle tout de rouge vêtu
n'ont pas très bien est ce que des
chouhada toit aux jo on va on arrive les
chéris voilà c'est que la télé sur la
ont gardé la main il montre emilie lopez
qui est parti fumer une cigarette la
vilaine et regardez les ils sont beaux
ils sont frais ils sont bas ils sont là
quoi parce que je ne les aime pas c'est
ce que je regardais mauvais élèves
je vais j'ai volé le micro il va
direction aux barbes on va se faire d un
peu d'argent qu'on est sortis du plateau
et la ramène micro donc là tous les ans
j'ai son sont en panique
[Musique]
les bernois n'a regardé les bons on se
prépare le divine et caroline sont en
pleine forme elle soit chez déchaîné lui
c'est ma fille tu peux plus ouais
carrément un vrai sapin côtés de son
chéri je me sens bien
alors y'a une bonne gueule d'un jeu sont
étonnamment pour équiper ces demoiselles
c'est très bien voilà regardez les comme
heureuse sommes heureuses hommes et toi
quand elle m'a dit que c'était quelque
soit l'état ça c'était sa vie voilà
comment tu te sens garder au passage
deux visages on ne vous dira donc loin
d'une bonne argum ça les jours se
suivent et ne se ressemblent quasiment
pas salut instagram
aujourd'hui on enchaîne les conférences
de rentrée des chaînes et radios et
cette fois ci c'est sous des airs celle
ci joue seule radio si je vous dis merci
l2 évidemment
[Musique]
enfin secrète on compte alors oui avec
des règles je suis très inquiet pour les
enfants qui prennent pas n'importe
comment 215 sans protection c'est une
boucherie
je veux absolument à londres auprès des
enfants y regarder on avec des très
grands blacks m qui vient de sortir son
album
en fait ça avec la famille en fait ça
avec son bras en fait ça avec holly bien
sûr je rentre et il ya un feat big flo
et oli sur l'album donc bollywood et son
épée gaulle écouter dès maintenant et
grâce à démarrer on est là direct avec
le pierrot
le meilleur de tous quand j'ai vu les
gars branchez vous c'était bien de
travail agathe football ce soir football
france andorre chèques tout le monde via
la régie tout le monde est là yahia il
est là il est là et il est là aussi il
ya des boutons partout 12 points
l'islande la turquie 12 points la france
point c'est pas le moment de jouer bon
je vous le dis c'est la victoire
impérative bonjour instagram ce matin
petite conférence à europe 1 radio qui a
changé totalement ce avec des programmes
en profondeur pour remonter sur le camp
des audiences on va voir ce que ça donne
bon ici tel choix sur les viennoiseries
[Musique]